ich will dass sie nicht
wir sind in offenbach die stadt liegt
direkt neben der deutschen
finanzmetropole frankfurt am main
hier wohnen viele kinder wie überall in
deutschland wachsen die meisten von
ihnen in typischen kleinfamilien auf
verschiedene generationen leben heute
nur noch selten unter einem dach team
süd besucht ein mehr generationen
wohnhaus hier sind junge und ältere
menschen eingezogen
dadurch dass wir so viele freunde hier
im haus haben die praktisch einem die
ganzen sorgen abnehme ja ich habe
überhaupt keine chance mehr
ihr leben singles familien und senioren
unter einem dach jeder hat seine eigene
wohnung aber die meisten bewohner
unternehmen viel gemeinsam und helfen
sich gegenseitig fast wie in einer
großfamilie
es wird von vielen als familienersatz
gesehen die sonst alleine leben würden
und die fühlen sich hier sehr wohl weil
sie in einer gemeinschaft leben leben
vor dem haus steht ein bücherschrank wo
sich jeder bücher ausleihen kann
doch mal einen richtigen eindruck
bekommt den schrank darf ein verein
treten
sorgt für gute laune in mehrgenerationen
wohnhaus und führt ein deutsches märchen
auf einen vorschlag machen
ich denke das märchen kennt ihr auch
rotkäppchen und der wolf das unterhalten
wir ein rotkäppchen und eine großmutter
erst mal müssen sich alle verkleiden
christine bekommt einen picknickkorb und
ein rotes kopftuch jonas wird zum wolf
und nasser verwandelt sich in eine
großmutter das mädchen spielt im wald
und es ist sehr brutal zu früh
rotkäppchen und der böse wolf riss die
großmutter und stellt rotkäppchen eine
fahne großmutter was hast du für brüssel
damit ich dich sehr cruz gute was hast
du damit ich dich besser packen kann
großmutter was hast du frei
damit ich dich besser fassen hatte der
wolf das gesagt
aber zum glück kommt der jäger vorbei
und schneidet dem schlafenden wolf den
bauch auf
am ende sind rotkäppchen und die
großmutter wieder frei und der böse wolf
ist tot
das märchen ist gut ausgegangen
berlin
würde da sagen also wie ich es empfunden
habe dass alle drei das hervorragend
gemacht haben und alle drei die punkte
für berlin
die hauptsache ist wir haben ticket das
wichtig ich habe so viel spaß gehabt als
das dicke da soll ich meine das ticket
ist heute nicht bei mir wichtig sondern
die laune heute also wir haben echt gut
seit ich denke das ist die dass die
beste zeit unter tage hier in
deutschland für ihren auftritt bekommen
alle drei gemeinsam ein weiteres ticket
also steht es 5 5
und jonas nimmt sich noch ein andenken
mit nach berlin
bern
berlin
nicht